what has contributed to your success so
far whether it's
watching something else someone else
seeing how they work
liking their style making mistakes
learning from them
belief in yourself meditation what do
you think has kept you i mean you've
been doing this i'm sorry with fyi 17
yeah years ago 15 years 15 years
and you'd been making films previously
because you went to film school you went
to two film schools
right no i went to one usc oh usc okay
what do you think's contributed to you
staying in the game because not
everybody
stays with this some people could make
one film they go to sundance they want
an award and then
either they can't find funding for the
next project and they walk away or
they get tired of it it's a lot of work
you're gonna get beat up
i think it's um in in my course of
working with
incarcerated youth um they've taught me
the the power of storytelling
it's really really really powerful
you know just the story for instance of
so a young black man who was one of my
students
while he was at kim gonzalez made a film
about him going home
and his fear about his father rejecting
him again his father always rejected him
right so
he made a film about this young black
man who goes home and the mother
is trying to make everything fine but
the father says get out of here i don't
want you in this house you're a juvenile
delinquent i don't want you here
and i want nothing to do with you so
this protagonist has to go through being
rejected yet again
by his father right so this is we
this was after the the film i talked
about about the mother who was
had uh substance abuse issues right and
so
um we invited the family
to see the film and i told antoine said
you got you have to take it out what the
film is about because
it can make him really ashamed or
uncomfortable you can't you can't just
do this to your dad so i talked to the
dad explained what it was said yeah yeah
whatever i'm just i don't even want to
go i'm just going because my wife wants
me to go so he went
and he saw this very tearful film about
a young boy who just would do
anything anything to be accepted and
loved by his father
the father was in tears
and i realized this is the power of film
like
but what's what's more beautiful about
the story is that
um uh the mother called me a week later
and
they went to family therapy to talk
about this stuff so
so this is how authentic storytelling
can lead
to healing
very interested in doing what i can to
contribute to the well-being of
humans whether they're in
angola or japan or the project itself
film has that power that the father and
the son
began a dialogue about how that
relationship could be healed and
repaired
all because he came up with this idea so
what keeps me going is
stories like this seeing how films and
stories
impact and heal people
that's what keeps me going have you ever
wanted to give up
yes when we pulled the plug on my film
in lake county probation i was like
wow i just had all these dark thoughts
but
my alumni my alum called me you know
from mexico
saying i i got deported but i'm teaching
filmmaking to incarcerated youth and
that kept me going again so see they
made
maybe i've lifted them when i'm i'm with
them but they call me out of the blue
sometimes and they lift me
imagine that so and adrian getting me to
stevie wonder i was like oh i'm never
going to make this film
so there's an exchange yes i'm teaching
them about filmmaking
teaching them to think critically about
their lives but they're teaching me too
they're embolding me
they're giving me permission to go
outside of what i learned at usc
get more radical and tell stories that
have power because they're authentic
to tell tell stories that will
hopefully challenge people to to find a
place of healing
you know that's what keeps me going
because the impact
powerful stories have on individuals
you've written a script that you said
was at sundance
you were working on it at one of the
labs can you talk about that
yeah it's it's make the moon and it's
about a
[Music]
it's semi-autobiographical but it's
about a a a mother i'm mixed-race my
mother is caucasian and uh
it's about a single mom who's caucasian
she has two
she has identical twin sons and the
father was not white and
um she loves one twin
she loves him because he's good i'm
burning my own spot here he's good in
the arts he's good at sports he
he's very communicative she loves him
she feels that he
is going to be the first of my family to
go to college the other son
is involved in gangs smoking weed
getting girls pregnant and dropping you
know not showing up to school
the one that she really loves ends up
tragically died in an accident and the
surviving twin
she forces him to become the twin she
loves
she said you be your brother then i can
love you
because i'm not doing that it's a film
about grief and about
broken relationships so it's intense
you wrote it years ago yeah i wrote it
um
about nine years ago and i i've avoided
it because
it's too close to home but um
i'm in a place now because i talked
about my um
experience recording with the youth
mountaineer tribe and these very
truthful conversations about
our mortality
and my father was diagnosed
with colon cancer um two years ago i
went home on christmas eve and
they had to take 90 of his calling out
and uh
i um had to change his dressing so he
had an
incision from his belly button up here
and i had to reach in
and that too had i started thinking i
don't know i'm not ready to lose my dad
like i don't want
like even though i don't see things the
way my parents do i don't want to lose
my parents yet
and i don't want to leave this place yet
but i
facing the possibility of my father
dying made me think of my own mortality
like i got to tell these stories i got
to get this film done
and get out of my phobic vortex
about dealing with the truth and get
this thing done
so as painful as it is
i was dwelling on how hard it is but now
i'm looking at how therapeutic it is i'm
going to be liberated when i tell the
story
because releasing a story to universe
can be very very
you know uh liberating so i'm at a place
now where
i'm ready to get it done as a matter of
fact i'm going to um
one of my founders to get a check for
half the amount of the budget
oh wow i'm ready to do the film
and i'm glad i haven't done the film yet
because if i did the film earlier
it would lack truth and power because of
what i went through
and i just think that you have to trust
the continuum
and a lot of artists get into these dark
spaces when we're not working
we're not on the set or we're not
writing you know we don't have a
deadline
i look at that time
my friend alex dorsey shared something
with me she said in those in between
moments where you have downtime
you are preparing your chalice
for future wine that's a very healthy
way of looking at it right
you are preparing your challenge for
future wine
you